il
là les attrape là
[Musique]
elle est pas en train de s'enfuir c'est
juste qu'elle est apte à spa voiture à
dans les gares christine
ne courais pas après l'argent devenez un
spécialiste et faites moi confiance
l'argent suivre
elle m'a dit que vous vouliez me parler
je te fais venir parce que je voudrais
que tu remplaces franck mais qui m'a
nommé directeur à sa place
et
[Musique]
c'est l'heure du grand sens
ce petit bruit sec que vous avez entendu
j'ai plongé dans moins d'un mètre de
profondeur
question est là présent tu te trouves à
l'hôpital au moment de l'impact de votre
tête est brusquement parti en avant ce
qui a brisé aux sixième et septième
vertèbre vous allez être atteint d'une
forme de paralysie sur le long terme que
vous ne pourrez peut-être pas recouvrer
plus de capacités que celle que vous
avez aujourd'hui mais cette fois que sa
mère rue
il
salue le voilà j'ai jamais remarcher mal
au moment tant attendu ce mardi c'est
parfois vie horrible tous les matins
réveil ont fait choix le vo rester dans
le miel il faut essayer suppositoire -
non partagé poker ce soir donc je te dis
à demain ce sera très doué et tous ces
trucs là je m'appelle adam bébé
américain fait
[Musique]
tu te rends pas compte de l'impact que
tu peux avoir sur tes collègues au
bureau si un jour je revenais bosser
pour nous mes performances seraient tout
simplement existantes c'est pas comme si
tu étais patineur artistique du vendait
des crédits par téléphone à bidouiller
un truc pour toi but sur ta main pourra
bientôt rasoir plus maintenant je
deviens si papa le temple est super je
suis pas très douée que tu c'est avec ce
genre de choses c'est à dire très bon en
tout cas tu es ici
qu'à partir de là
et aucune idée des épreuves que tu peux
traverser dans ta vie de tous les jours
depuis le début c'est patiente avec moi
j'étais en colère soir là elle m'a
toujours traité comme universal est ce
que j'ai fait ce que tu merde
mais aussi quoi proches
[Musique]